foreign
[Music]
hello my name is Andrea O'Hara and I am
one of our technical Specialists on the
gene whiz NGS team and today I'll be
presenting to you advancing aav novel
synthesis and sequencing solutions for
gene therapy research
at geneviz we have a number of different
proprietary protocols for both
sequencing and synthesis of aav this
includes solutions for the Upstream
Discovery and identification
pre-clinical development and downstream
clinical development and use and Within
These we have a number of different
solutions at our disposal including
Solutions around next Generation
sequencing sanger-based services and
synthetic DNA Solutions I'm going to
take you throughout the aav life cycle
and introduce some of the different
solutions we have to offer that
Encompass this entire Spectrum
foreign
-associated virus or aav is an ideal
delivery vehicle for the for gene
therapy The aav genome consists of a
left and right ITR as well as the rep
and Cat proteins however this molecule
can be utilized to insert our own
targeted recombinant gene or genes of
Interest the packaging size is limited
to approximately 5 KB but one thing to
keep in mind is that these left and
right itrs are critical for virus
replication and encapsidation
in fact maintaining the ITR throughout
production is critical for the entire
process for aav quality and efficiency
there's been a number of Publications
that have covered this in great detail
but the itrs are really important for
aav productivity and capsidation residue
of non-recombatant aav encapsidated DNA
the Affinity of the rep protein and
transduction efficiency just to name a
few
a key highlight if left undetected would
reduce reproducibility of experiments
both within and across Laboratories and
potentially cause significant delay of
vector translation into clinical utility
so what are some of the main challenges
when working with the itrs the first is
actually sequencing the ITR the RTR
region itself which is shown here on the
upper right hand side consists of this
t-shaped hairpin Loops which makes it
very difficult to sequence and we need
to know what is the actual sequence of
the ITR on the plasmid
the second component is that the itrs
are really prone to mutation during
plasmid preparation so so how can we get
a good batch of aav plasmid without ITR
mutations
enter gene whiz we have a number of
different aav solutions to ensure a good
start for high quality aav manufacturing
this includes our proprietary Sanger
sequencing method that can read through
the itrs ITR correction and aav plasmid
synthesis and finally aav plasmid prep
we also offer some Next Generation
sequencing solutions for the aav ITR
sequencing
I'd like to take you through these in a
little bit more detail
so the Jean was ITR sequencing is able
to actually read through a full-length
icr the existing Sanger sequencing
method quickly drops off throughout that
125 base pair hairpin Loop however with
our proprietary sequencing method we can
read cleanly throughout the entire 125
base pair region on the left hand side
is showing existing Sanger sequencing
methods and you can see how that
sequence really just drops off with our
proprietary method we're able to read
through the entire 125 base pair region
of that hairpin Loop this is an ideal
approach for confirming your plasmid
sequence and making sure that you have
great uh ITR fidelity
we do also offer this at the glp grade
so the glp grade aav ITR sequencing
confirmation is FDA compliance and
includes PCR amplification and Sanger
sequencing of the ITR regions using our
proprietary protocol
additionally glp grade sequencing
confirmation includes QA oversight a
study report signed glp compliance
statements and archival study analysis
of up to five years at a minimum
looking for a Next Generation sequencing
option we also recommend our Pac bio
approach which is a great alternative
for high throughput screening and
contamination testing of your ITR
sequences this is going to actually be
sequencing of the entire plasmid so this
will include the ITR region as well as
the rest of the plasmid and the backbone
this is a contiguous single long read
molecule so we'll get the whole plasmid
with high accuracy again single molecule
resolution means that we can look at a
mixed frequency a population or a clonal
population to confirm the clonality of
that population and we can Multiplex
multiple plasmid preps for high
throughput testing this is a really
ideal approach to confirm that you have
a high fidelity of your plasmid stalks
that there is not any low-level
contaminants and if there are to
determine what they are
now once we have uh our ITR sequence
known we have a full plasmid preparation
workflow to confirm maintain and correct
the ITR as needed so again starting out
with that aav ITR Sanger sequencing
approach if we have a mixed population
we can do screening and selection to
isolate the Clones that have the intact
ITR and stop and stop propagating remove
those that have any sort of truncated or
mutated itrs and carry those through to
the plasmid preparation
um if we are looking to actually
synthesize a plasmid or make plasmid
edits we can clone intact ITR regions to
it or if we have a plasmid that's been
put together but we notice that there
are some inconsistencies within the icr
we do offer icr correction to fix these
regions before cloning our scale up
once we have a great plasmid that is
full intact and ready to go we have a
number of solutions to take us moving
forward
so again we have sequenced our ITR and
corrected it as needed now we can move
on to our actual plasmid preparation and
again you'll remember once there's two
main steps here that are really critical
for this icr the first is confirming the
sequence but the second is maintaining
that correct ITR sequence throughout
plasmid preparation
so to take you through a little bit more
detail on this I'd like to walk you
through a case study so at Gene whiz we
have several proprietary cell lines that
can maintain best maintain ITR Integrity
throughout the plasmid prep process
in this case study we took eight
different aav plasmids and transformed
them across five different cell lines
two of them are our Gene with cell lines
which have been optimized for
maintaining the ITR across the entire
process as well as three other companies
proprietary cell lines
for each of these we picked eight clones
from each plate and then did the ITR
sequencing with our Sanger method to
confirm the ITR integrity
what we found is that the gene was
proprietary aav strains work best for
aav plasmids especially those with easy
to mutate itrs
among the eight aav plasmas that were
tested three were particularly
challenging in terms of icr Integrity
for plasmid preparation both Gene was
aav strains can can obtain clothes with
intact itrs for all three plasmids
whereas the other commercial strains
fail to generate clones with intact itrs
for at least two of the plasmids so you
can see here on the left hand side we
have the overall icr integrity and on
the right the number of clones that
actually had that intact icr
what we can see here is that altogether
Gene whiz has a greater than 98 success
rate after just the first attempt for
plasmid prep using these proprietary
cell lines
now once we've generated our full intact
plasmids we're ready to move ahead with
the packaging of the cell line and
generating final aav viral particles
we're going to take all of these pieces
together and generate the aav particles
but once we have these aav virus
particles we need to confirm that we
have everything in there exactly as
specified no more no less that means
that we want to confirm that we have the
correct recombinant aav viral genome
packaged within the viral particles and
that we don't have any impurities or
contaminants also packaged Within These
aav virus particles
this is a really critical step for the
entire pipeline because impurities
packaged within those recombinant aav
vectors can seriously affect clinical
safety impurities can include things
like defective particles residual
proteins from the helper viruses or
contaminant DNA from multiple sources
including the plasmid backbone itself
the cell residual cell DNA from uh from
the growth or the helper viruses
I'm highlighting here a few key
Publications on the right hand side
but the main take-home message here is
that it's imperative to confirm package
material since the introduction of
incorrect sequences can trigger unwanted
immune responses
and measuring the level of DNA
contamination prior to clinical use can
help reduce the risk of adverse side
effects
to this we have two main applications
for Next Generation sequencing post
packaging the first is with alumina
sequencing which is a short read
technology and the seconds is Pac bio
which is a long read technology I'd like
to take you through the details of both
of these as there are pros and cons to
both approaches
so as I mentioned Illumina is a short
read sequencing technology with this
method we will go for a very high depth
of coverage but again we're going to be
using short reads that will be
bioinformatically mapped back to our
reference genomes this is ideal for
checking contamination and quantitation
of those contaminants within that
population again we have two main
focuses confirm what the recombinants
aav virus is and see if there's anything
else in there because we're doing this
very deep sequencing we can get
resolution at a very low frequency of
potential contaminants and this again
can include the backbone helper plasmids
as well as any residual cell DNA we're
also going to be able to get a really
nice deep view of our recombinant aav
genome
and so we'll be able to quantitate any
mutations small insertion deletions and
edits that might be occurring within our
aav genome when we think alumina we
think quantitation again deep sequencing
so we're going to get a great idea of
the frequency of these changes that we
might have or contaminants present
conversely we also have packed by a long
read sequencing this is going to be
single molecule resolution that means
that for every piece of DNA we have
we're going to sequence the full thing
from nsand this could be short dnase or
long dnas depending upon what's inside
of those viral particles we're going to
be doing a mixed population analysis of
this pool of viral stock our depth of
coverage here though is going to be more
moderate
so this approach is ideal for
confirmation of our sequence Fidelity
again because we're looking at the
entire molecule end to end we're going
to be able to identify mutation events
or combination events Fusion events
we're also going to be able to look at
truncation events within our itrs or
even earlier and we're going to be able
to read cleanly all the way through that
five Prime and three prime icr
when we look at our full-length species
of our recombinant aav we will be able
to identify the abundance of variants
but again we're not sequencing as deeply
so we won't have that Ultra deep
resolution for very very low level
variance
the other thing we'll be able to do is
resolve the size
so because we're looking at that single
molecule resolution and going from Full
end to end
if we look at any contaminants that we
may have present we'll be able to see if
they are all the same size as our
recombinant aav or do we have smaller
things that are contaminating our
overall viral particle pool
one of the caveats with a pack bio
sequencing is that it does have a size
bias meaning that it's more uh it will
proactively or selectively sequence
smaller species that means that Pac bio
is not ideal for determining frequency
of contamination or for determining the
frequency of size of particles but
within a particular size range we can
determine frequency of changes within it
so whereas alumina we think frequency
packed by we think Fidelity so what is
my overall molecule looking like and if
I do have any contaminants what are the
size of those contaminants
so an overview of these two methods pack
bio we're going to get full length aav
Fidelity again that entire genome
end-to-ends will be able to identify the
frequency of the changes within the
full-length genome and the size of our
contaminants
aluminous sequencing is short read
sequencing it's going to be very very
very deep so we will get a really
excellent view of the frequency of the
changes but because it's not that full
molecule we won't know if we have
multiple changes happening in the same
species or if these are independent
species changes we're going to get that
frequency but we're not going to get the
full molecule resolution and we'll have
an excellent view of the frequency of
the contaminations to a very low level
ultimately the best approach here is
going to be using both Technologies
because of their strengths and
weaknesses together we're going to get
the most comprehensive view of what our
full-length aav looks like any high and
low level frequency changes the amount
of contaminants we have and the size of
the contaminants and when we put this
together we'll have a comprehensive view
of everything that's happening within
that final viral particle pool
now at Jane whiz we offer fall end to
end aav NGS workflows you can select for
either pack bio Illumina or both this
workflow includes extraction from viral
particles second strand synthesis or
conversion from the single stranded DNA
to a double-stranded DNA Library
preparation sequencing and
bioinformatics Analysis
our bioinformatics analysis includes
standardized reports this will have
detailed variant reporting that's where
we'll find out about the frequency of
our changes if any within the
recombinant aav genome we will also have
advanced mapping statistics this will
tell us about host contamination helper
plasmid contamination and aav plasmid
backbone contamination and we'll be able
to detect a truncation hot spots
including the three prime and five Prime
ITR sequences and so I'm showing you
just a few examples here and again this
is all included within that
comprehensive workflow
yeah
we also do offer a glp grade viral gdna
or cdna Sanger sequencing confirmation
this is compliant with the FDA and this
includes a few different options so this
would be PCR and Sanger sequencing
verification including genome
integration and cell bin confirmation
the starting materials accepted include
viral particles viral Vector Master
virus stock genomic DNA mRNA or Cell
Pellets and again with the glp grade
Sanger sequencing confirmation this
entire project will include QA oversight
a study report signed glp compliance
statements and archival study analysis
of five years at a minimum
now once we've completed our entire aav
packaging process the next step are
going to be our post infection Solutions
so again thinking back to the entire
end-to-end aav workflow once we've
completed our initial Discovery phases
we have our pre-clinical and
post-clinical phases or pre-clinical and
clinical phases if you will
we can use Next Generation sequencing
for a number of the post packaging
Solutions during these pre-clinical and
clinical phases and I have this broken
up into three main components the first
is going to be transcript or gene
expression profiling both during and
after infection the second is going to
be about immune response during and
after infection and finally
characterization of the host genome
which is available at research use only
in CLIA the top two faces I'm going to
take you through all of these in more
detail but the first two are at ruo only
so the first one uh the transcript or
gene expression profiling during and
after infection we have a number of
different sequencing solutions that can
be utilized for gene expression or
transcript expression profiling both
during expression during infection and
after reflection infection
bulk rna-seq or standard rnac can be
used for things like treatment versus
control or dosage response and this is
typically going to be alumina based RNA
sequencing
we also offer single cell RNA sequencing
this is really ideal for uh doing a much
deeper dive again treated versus control
or dosage response but looking for a
cell single cell resolution or cell type
resolution of changes especially
critical if we think we are going to be
targeting specific cell types with our
recombinant aav Vector so that we can
see where those changes are occurring at
what frequency and is it having an
impact on multiple cell types or
differing impacts on cell types
we also offer pack bio ISO seek which is
isoform detection and Confirmation
really ideal if our recombinant aav is
going to be providing a different uh
transcript versus something that's going
to be already present in the cell the
idea here being instead of looking for
something that is
um in addition to or looking for a
species that's in addition to another
one that's already present versus uh say
an example where we are introducing
something that is no longer present with
our novel gene therapy
finally we have digital spatial
profiling or DSP this is on the
nanostring geomix and this is ideal for
nc2 identification of expression with
this we would actually take a tissue
sample and look for the expression
within the tissue sample again really
ideal for thinking of targeting specific
cells or cell types and we want to see
that within the 3D context of the tissue
now we can use these similar approaches
to actually look at the immune response
and immune profiling both during and
after infection and this is really
thinking about now looking at the the
immune components in particular so all
of these have options that focus more
specifically on the immunoprofiling
versus the standard expression profiling
and for each of these solutions they are
both a standalone or an add-on
meaning you can look at just
immunosequencing alone or you can
combine immunosequencing with uh with
transcript or gene expression sequencing
again all of these services are at the
research use only level
but we do offer have we also offer some
solutions that are going to be at the
ruo and CLIA levels and so here this is
where we're going to think about
characterization of the host genome this
can be with whole genome sequencing at
standard or low pass whole genome
sequencing
standard whole genome sequencing is
going to give us a high level of
coverage a low pass whole genome
sequencing is ideal for snip level
detection this is also really ideal if
we want to Ideal if we want to catalog
our cohort for the downstream clinical
trial so if we're looking for say
variability or differences in our
full-on solution or we want to get some
snip level genome profiling to identify
additional markers
this also includes targeted sequencing a
whole exome sequencing or even targeted
panels all of these offerings are
available at research use only or at the
CLIA stage
and so to recap we have a number of
different proprietary protocols for both
sequencing and synthesis of aav
molecules
from our sanger-based services this
included aav ITR sequencing at both the
our research use only and glp compliance
levels our synthetic DNA Solutions
included both GNA DNA synthesis Gene
synthesis plasmid synthesis as well as
plasmid prep
finally we offered a number of different
Next Generation sequencing Solutions and
this included a whole genome sequencing
of the recombinant aav vector itself as
well as a whole genome sequencing
solutions for the clinical trial
um and pre-clinical stages additionally
we offer a number of Downstream uh
approaches for the post-infection
solutions within the next Generation
sequencing stages
um at Jean was we're here to offer you
complete and comprehensive full
end-to-end sequences or full end-to-end
Solutions
um and so with that I would like to
actually go ahead and take any questions
that we may have
okay and I see we have a number of
questions so I'm going to go ahead and
just read these off
um the first question is for recombinant
aav sequencing how much uh
single-stranded DNA do I need or or how
many particles do I need this is a great
question so uh for aluminous sequencing
we typically want about 500 nanograms of
DNA at a minimum and that typically
corresponds to an area about 1e to the
11th to one e to the 12th viral
particles
for pack bio sequencing um this is a
much hungrier technology so we typically
need more uh DNA and so for this
approach I recommend
um one to two micrograms of DNA
um per um
per sample and so that corresponds to
closer to a neighborhood of uh one e to
the 12th to one e to the 13th particles
if you're looking to do both
Technologies for your viral vectors I do
recommend shooting for that one e to the
13th viral particles again we offer full
that that package is a full package so
you can either provide the single
stranded DNA after extraction or you can
just provide the particles and we can do
the extraction as a part of that
comprehensive workflow
okay
um the next question is
um how much does it cost
um so it really depends on which
approach you're working for here um so
obviously we have a number of Next
Generation sequencing Solutions as well
as saying or sequencing Solutions
um I do recommend if you're interested
in learning more about cost about the
different approaches if you're thinking
of you know using a multiple different
approaches
um that the best place to go is to our
website genewiz.com we do have
um an aav Solutions webpage where you
can actually click through and select
each of these different
um technology options including both the
Sanger and Next Generation sequencing
Solutions and you can read more about it
but also you can request pricing and
quote information on our website
okay
um and with that I think we'll actually
wrap up here so um if you do have any
questions that I didn't answer
um or you would like to discuss further
I would invite you to visit us at our
booth
um I will be there
um after I will be there
uh throughout this this conference uh to
answer any questions that you may have
um so please feel free to come over to
the booth and reach out you can also get
additional information
um at our booth regarding any of the
solutions you've seen here as well as
some of the other solutions that we do
offer at G us
and with that I will go ahead and say
goodbye have a great day everybody